and in our next half hour we will talk
with johnson and johnson
johnson johnson ceo about the company's
plan to get a hundred million doses
by june while vaccine distribution is
ramping up there is a new worrying drop
in covid testing across the country
right now the u.s averages 1.4 million
tests a day
that's down from a high of 1.9 million
in mid-january
less testing could slow down our ability
to track
outbreaks of the virus our lead national
correspondent david begno
is in los angeles david what's driving
this decline in testing
well anthony the main reason is they're
turning testing sites into vaccine sites
and it makes sense right but we took a
look at the data
and when you take into account los
angeles county where we are this morning
it appears testing is down 34
in the last month that's a pretty
sizable chunk and what that means is
people who are relying on testing sites
say monthly to
keep working are showing up at testing
sites like where we are this morning the
va hospital in los angeles
folks are showing up to see an empty
parking lot and they're thinking hey
wait a minute what happened
hair stylist amanda shuttleworth feels
like getting tested is something that
she
owes her clients i see clients regularly
so it's my responsibility to make sure
that i got regular testing
so how regularly were you going i would
probably say like once a month
she had tested positive back in december
and so she wanted a follow-up test just
to reassure her clients that she was
virus free
but when she went to her usual testing
site it was gone
it was like a ghost town there's nothing
there her testing site at the va
hospital parking lot in los
angeles was closed entirely and the city
is now turning other testing sites like
dodgers
stadium into vaccine sites and it's
happening in cities across california
we were averaging 330 000
tests a day towards the end of december
early january
and now we're below 200 000 tests a day
that is dr mark galey california's
secretary of health and human services
he says with various strains of coded
spreading across california
mass testing is as important today as
it's ever been we can't ramp down
testing
too much otherwise if we did see another
surge
we're never going to be able to track it
and we are not out of the woods yet
the only way you track a variant is by
starting with a positive test
so it's going to be key over the next
weeks and months
and you know the upcoming vaccines could
be a part of the solution
there are the new shots from johnson and
johnson novavax and astrazeneca
that can be stored in normal
refrigerators in doctor's offices
and that is a game changer says cbs news
medical contributor dr david agus
every year we give flu shots and 60
percent of the country is vaccinated
with an influenza vaccine
those are done in doctors offices and in
community hospitals
we have to start to transition vaccines
there so we can go
back to testing at the large centers
there are other doctors who say listen
we need to focus more on vaccines
than we do on testing do you agree well
vaccines are what's going to get us out
of this pandemic period at the same time
we have to figure out an
alternative way to do testing knowing if
you have or you don't have the virus
is critical for your behavior do i
quarantine do i stay home
you need testing to determine that
makes sense right as for our main
character amanda shuttleworth she was
able to find testing she finally after
spending some time on her phone looking
for a testing site found
a rite aid in south los angeles she went
through a drive-through and tested
negative
for the first time in nearly three
months if you're a mayor county
executive or governor and you're
watching this
this story's for you don't forget about
testing
yeah it still matters david thank you
very much we appreciate it